now and thank you for joining us on 8
news now at four I'm Brian Loftus and
I'm Vanessa Murphy an early morning fire
rips through an apartment building
killing one person and sending seven to
the hospital including a firefighter 18
also without a home we also learned that
one person still unaccounted for the
blaze broke out just after five o'clock
at the tides on Charleston that is on
West Charleston at Torrey Pines 8 news
now reporter Victoria Saha explains why
this fire was so very difficult to put
out
Tuesday worried about the
wee other buildings
the early morning fire waking residents
up in a panic welcome to the sirens
first and then open
Alexander olomeiji lives right next to
the building that caught fire so I thank
God that it wasn't me the charge
structure still standing fire Crews
working to put out hot spots I saw
children trying to escape
um but yeah it was just just a lot of
fire just so just a lot of smoke people
self-evacuated the smoke alarms work
really well Las Vegas fire chief Robert
Nolan confirming to eight news now that
some residents were jumping to safety
before help could arrive unfortunately
while combing through the rubble one
person was found deceased we did have
water on the fire within five minutes
the Red Cross also helping families who
are now without a home in total I was
told that 11 adults and seven children
are displaced the Red Cross is working
to get them a place to stay tonight and
provide them with clothing and food
Victoria sahab 8 News Now